no final as multas só meu é isso ai
[Música]
pessoal de quem falar que sejam muito
bem vindos a um pneu o que mostrar de
que um vídeo de um sutil que se tornou
viral aqui no youtube entra na quinta
feira eu vou fazer o desafio da bola de
aluminío prefeito e no final o pessoal
lá vou colocar um exclusivo dentro da
boca de um menino e vamos ver o que vai
acontecer em branco
então acho que isto se foi realmente
consegue explodir esta bola não sai a
gente está por isso só se quiserem ver
mais vídeos desde que deixei muito
líquido espírito e se vocês forem nós
aqui no canal que inscreva estamos quase
a ficar os quatro milhões e infelizmente
o youtube não está a procurar os filhos
portanto se você pudesse isso na teoria
pois como eu fui comprar todo o alumínio
que eu precisava eu acho que é
suficiente tem 30 metros mais 30 metros
mais 30 metros da 90 90 metros do folha
do mínimo é muita luz ninguém também
comprei que muita o checo podem ver têm
muitas folhas espanha está mais fina que
tenham me chamais grossa chegou eu vou
usar para fazer a maior parte do
trabalho ea deixa mais fina eu vou usar
como acabamento e agora só vamos ter um
cuidado porque está no quarto eu preciso
que alguém filme portanto vamos acordar
vai hoje vamos gravar a bola de alumínio
perfeitamente o que que é isso não
acontecerá nem de gravar só vai
trabalhando mais bonito é para nós a
explodir
a cantora que eu acho que eu sei que
preciso espírito muito difícil fazer
futebol é preciso pelo menos 8 9 horas
porque demora muito e foi para a bola e
ela fica perfeita isso é bom ver esse
tempo tudo mais velocidade para a
cultura é e acho que o emprego a mais
só estou fazendo um kit festa bola bem
grande teste imposto por causa do
tamanho mas nem assim a exata elenco é
muito pequena
o indivíduo toque pessoal à cinta no
boneco também acho que sim
agora é só uma toalha e vai incluir no
campeonato a entrevista é só tenho mais
forças não tentarem pouca força não
estou triste mas vai ficar parado lá e
pegar agora isso não é possível e assim
é o cara e desmantelar esta que numa
zona muito mais sólida porque estava
desabando muito portanto uma clara lei
controlado antes do trabalhador embora
as obras também revela sol e deputados
que aqui vou conseguir fazer sim é só
ver que uma racha no meio do ano eu não
vou fazer nada com isso
[Música]
ok vamos lá tentar deixar
as pessoas a rachel ok emprego
do lado enfrenta do avaí era influente
do lado
agora o carvão de um erro foi assim que
o porvir a e agora vai falar assim é pra
ficar mais ou menos simétrico
eu não sei se estão também o suficiente
mas eu acho que conseguimos com a
jaqueta que eu vou começar com este
hotel pertence uma área maior e eu já
vou pensar mais pequena eu acho que
cinco civis e mais rápido fica a ficar
positivo também vai ficar a mesma ficar
o oco o poder da profissão assim né
mas
ok porém já estamos feira mas somente
prefeito de rio agora outro cargo até o
que usar mais porque a ficar aí está
mesmo pensando a cissa que teve a esse
mesmo assim estamos com uma coisa é ver
meu deus estou cansado do estado muito
bravo a fazer a troca do brasil
não posso ou não posso espantam se tomou
pra si uma clara do criciúma é muito
difícil não era a mãe não é hora já tá
né a decisão foi tomada de tempo para o
rapto por acho que ela está perfeita
assim uma espécie humana aproveitados
por tanto tempo para mostrar que ninguém
aqui
mas isso por aí tentando abater com isso
da cabeça
então a ii volta da uma hora no qual
colocar aquele peso que é pra fazer
opção e rodar o mesmo tempo que eu posso
usar quem pensa o peso pessoa ou ganhar
a estrada é agora fazer pressão e rodar
alguns em profissões mais técnica fazer
essa boa saída
dá para sentir as imperfeições mesmo o
pessoal já estava perto do astro foi
possível que eu consigo
olha aí tá linda onu deixa a wish we
[Música]
costa
será que vai dar a bosta é o próximo a
deixar o vídeo e já olha tá ficando isso
apoio no final do ano e deixar o dedo
isso aqui tá tudo sujo já gastei um
instituto olha só para aí tem rixa aqui
não foi não é um pano o mesmo
[Música]
a área está cansado o que eu já não quer
produzir
não fosse isso teria uma mão amiga honda
saiu se promover top 15 a 123 vagas
cuidado pra não deixar a liderança com
isso é uma técnica nova câmera que o
luxa já que campo mourão e da chegada
pois nem mail
[Música]
e audacioso boto feita de alumínio aí a
culpa também fechava bem que ainda
faltava um pouco mas acabou lixo acho
que estou afundar na água
olha aí vamos partir agora o pessoal não
se sabe tudo já experimentou isto mas eu
acho que ela ganha nada porque acho que
as coisas vão gostar eu fui porque
estava em 2 3 bilhões ou o meu deus meu
deus meu deus
a ruim é boi é o então agora é só estar
aqui é assim eu vou apoiar a equipe
preta e agora é possível em forma e
durável e baixos o técnico embora 3 2
num resultado
agora ele tá muito doença
agora meu banco
isso mostra bull tudo preto o hubble às
leis de um sistema para isso estuda uma
parte que eu nem sei onde fui parar e é
isso que só espero que vocês tenham
gostado que deste vídeo já sabe quanto o
nosso oua em que neste vídeo estava
inscrito no canal que inscrevam e
partilhem com o nosso time é esse que só
fiquem bem até a próxima
[Música]